,
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
>> Greg: THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE
CRACKING DOWN ON FREEDOM OF
SPEECH DAYS AFTER ELON MUSK'S
TWITTER TAKEOVER.
SECRETARY MAYORKAS ANNOUNCING
PLANS FOR WHAT HE CALLS A
DISINFORMATION GOVERNANCE BOARD
TO COMBAT THIS INFORMATION AHEAD
OF THE MIDTERMS.
>> WE HAVE JUST ESTABLISHED A
GOVERNANCE BOARD IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
TO MORE EFFECTIVELY COMBAT THIS
THREAT, NOT ONLY TO ELECTION
SECURITY BUT OUR HOMELAND
SECURITY.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S TO
PREVENT THIS INFORMATION, I AM
NOT SURE WHO OPPOSES THAT
EFFORT.
>> Greg: I SMELL A RAT BE THE
GROUP WILL BE LED BY A FAR LEFT
EXPERT WHO CALLS TRUMP -- A
CAMPAIGN PRODUCT IN 2020.
SHE'S ALSO BEEN VOCAL ABOUT HER
TO STAY FOR ELON MUSK SAYING SHE
SHUDDERS TO THINK ABOUT THE
BUILDING OR TAKING OVER TWITTER.
ANTI-MUSK FEVER PRACTICALLY
PREREQUISITE FOR ANY JOB IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
ELIZABETH WARREN TAKING ANOTHER
SHOT AT THE BILLIONAIRE LAST
NIGHT.
>> WE NEED RULES OF THE ROAD AND
THERE ARE GOING TO BE RULES.
THE ONLY QUESTION IS WILL
ELON MUSK DECIDE ALL THE RULES
BY HIMSELF IN A DARK ROOM?
OR IS IT GOING TO BE THE CASE
THAT WE ARE GOING TO DECIDE THIS
AS A COUNTRY?
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE THE RULES
IN A DEMOCRACY?
RULES OF THE ROAD COULD HELP
FACILITATE THAT KIND OF
COMPETITION AND FRANKLY, BREAK
THE STRANGLEHOLD OF SOMEONE LIKE
ELON MUSK COMING IN AT JUST
OWNING THE WHOLE THING.
>> Greg: THEY WILL SAY
ANYTHING.
A JUDGE, WHAT A COINCIDENCE THAT
THIS IS JUST HAPPENING THIS
WEEK.
THERE'S NO CONNECTION WHATSOEVER
TO THE ELECTIONS OR ELON MUSK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Judge Jeanine: I AGREE WITH
YOU, IT IS A COINCIDENCE BUT ON
THE OTHER SIDE DON'T YOU HAVE TO
SAY, ISN'T IT AMAZING HOW FAST
THEY GOT THIS DISINFORMATION
GROUP TOGETHER?
I MEAN, GIVEN HOW LONG IT TOOK
THEM TO GET WEAPONS TO THE
UKRAINE, EVEN ZELENSKYY AT HOW
DISORGANIZED THEY WERE COMING
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN.
WHY DIDN'T THEY TAKE THEIR
WEAPONS OUT OF AFGHANISTAN TO
GIVE THEM TO UKRAINE?
THAT WOULD'VE BEEN A SMARTER
CHOICE.
YOU'VE GOT BARACK OBAMA COMING
OUT AND SAYING WE WANT CONTENT
MODERATION.
NOW YOU'VE GOT THESE PEOPLE
SAYING WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
DISINFORMATION GROUP WHERE WE
CAN SAY WHAT WE THINK IS NOT
CORRECT AND WE SUFFER UNDER
THEIR THUMB FOR FOUR YEARS OF
THE RUSSIA COLLUSION DELUSION
ALONG WITH THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP BEING RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
I MEAN, THEY'VE LIED TO US
REPEATEDLY.
BUT THE ONLY THING THAT THEY
WANT IS TO BE ABLE TO CONTROL
WHAT WE SAY AND WHAT WE SAY TO
EACH OTHER AND WHAT WE THINK, SO
THEIR HATRED OF ELON MUSK, IT IS
PALPABLE.
JOY REID LAST NIGHT, TALKED
ABOUT, HE JUST MISSES APARTHEID
OF SOUTH AFRICA,
ELIZABETH WARREN.
THINK OF WHAT THEY ARE DOING TO
HIM BEHIND-THE-SCENES, IF THEY
ARE DOING THIS RIGHT IN FRONT OF
EVERYBODY, AND IT IS REAL CLEAR,
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES ALLOWS FOR
FREE SPEECH.
NO GOVERNMENT HAS THE RIGHT TO
MODERATE, DEFINE OR HOLD A LIMIT
FREE SPEECH BE THAT IS IN THE
CONSTITUTION, IT IS IN THE
FIRST AMENDMENT FOR A REASON AND
IT IS CONFIRMED BY THE
SUPREME COURT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN IN THEIR ATTEMPT TO MUSCLE
US UNLESS IT IS OBSCENITIES IS
REALLY AN EFFORT TO CONTROL THIS
COUNTRY IN A WAY THAT WE'VE
NEVER SEEN.
>> Greg: JASON, YOU ARE FOR
FREE SPEECH YOU ARE NOW LABELED
A FREE SPEECH ABSOLUTIST LIKE
SOMEHOW YOU ARE AN EXTREMIST.
DID YOU HEAR HE IS AN
ABSOLUTIST?
HERE IS THE THING, WHAT CAN THEY
ACTUALLY DO?
DID THEY SIT AND WATCH
"THE FIVE" AND SAY, GREG SAID HE
WOULD BET JESSE A MILLION BUCKS
HE COULD LIFT HIS MUG.
HE'S NOT ACTUALLY GOING TO PAY
THE MILLION DOLLARS, IS HE?
DO THEY HAVE ANY AUTHORITY TO DO
ANYTHING?
>> Jason: I DON'T THINK THEY
HAVE THE AUTHORITY BUT THEY ARE
GOING TO TRY.
SECRETARY MAYORKAS LOOKED LIKE
HE WAS LIVE FROM BEIJING TELLING
US HOW EVERYBODY IS, WHAT THEY
CAN SAY, HOW THEY CAN SAY IT,
THIS IS ALLOWABLE, THIS IS NOT
ALLOWABLE.
ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO OR SO IT IS
CALLED STOP ONLINE PIRACY ACT,
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS, THEY
TRIED TO GIVE HOMELAND SECURITY
UNILATERAL AUTHORITY TO TAKE
DOWN WEBSITES, SO THIS IS A
PLAYBOOK THEY WENT TO UNDER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, THEY ARE
TRYING TO DO IT NOW BUT I THINK
WHAT THEY'RE REALLY AFRAID OF
WITH ELON MUSK'S HE IS GOING TO
PEEL BACK AND EXPOSE WHAT WAS
GOING ON WITH THE SHADOW
BANNING, ABOUT HOW THEY'VE
MANIPULATED THE SOCIAL MEDIA TO
BE FOR THEIR TEAM ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE OF THE ISLAND
AGAINST CONSERVATIVES.
HE'S ONLY SUCCESSFUL IF HE IS
POLITICALLY NEUTRAL IF HE ALLOWS
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS TO GO
OUT THERE.
>> Greg: THE FACT THAT THIS
EXPERT OR PERSON IN CHARGE
PUSHED THAT LETTER OF THE 50
FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
OFFICIALS, CALLED THE LAPTOP
FAKE AND THEN YOU HAVE SECRETARY
MAYORKAS, THAT WAS PROBABLY ONE
OF THE BIGGEST MISINFORMATION
SCAMS.
HOW CAN THEY PULL THIS OFF?
HOW CAN THIS HAPPEN?
>> Dana: IT'S INTERESTING,
I'VE BROUGHT THIS UP BEFORE,
REMEMBER PRESIDENT BARTLETT ON
THE SHOW?
SHE WAS A REPUBLICAN AND THEY
MADE HER WORK IN THE BASEMENT
AND EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE THEY
WOULD PULL HER UPSTAIRS AND SAY,
ASK A REPUBLICAN ABOUT THIS AND
SHE IS LIKE, I WOULDN'T DO THAT.
YOU CAN DO THIS BUT NOT THAT.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT ANYBODY AT
THIS MEETING SAYS, DO YOU THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE A PROBLEM THAT
SHE'S GOING TO BE IN CHARGE?
WELL, WHY WOULD THAT POSSIBLY
BE?
WOULDN'T IT HAVE OCCURRED TO
THEM SO THEY DON'T HAVE AN EARLY
WARNING SYSTEM?
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THIS UNDER THE
CONGRESSIONAL ACT, IT'S TOO
BROAD, I GET THAT BUT THIS IS
CERTAINLY NOT INCLUDED.
THE THING ABOUT ELON MUSK, HE
DOESN'T CARE IF HE'S LIKE AND
IT'S DRIVING THE LEFT ABSOLUTELY
CRAZY.
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A MODEL
FOR THIS, IT ALSO DOESN'T WORK
THAT WELL ALTHOUGH THEY TRY,
CALLED THE BROADCASTING BOARD OF
GOVERNORS AND ITS CONTROVERSIAL
UNDER EVERY PRESIDENT PEERED THE
WAY THEY SET IT UP AS THERE FOUR
REPUBLICANS AND FORGO DEMOCRATS
AND THE CHAIR OF THE BOARD AS
THE SECRETARY OF STATE, WHOEVER
THAT HAPPENS TO BE AT THE TIME
AND THEY TRY TO ADJUDICATE
THINGS.
THAT MIGHT BE A BETTER WAY.
YOU JUST CAN'T HAVE BUREAUCRATS
GOING TO BE IN CHARGE OF
FREE SPEECH, THEY MISSED THE
ENTIRE THING, IT DOESN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE.
ALSO SOMETHING VERY STRANGE IS
GOING ON, I'M NOT BUYING THAT
ALL THE SUDDEN 100,000 MORE
PEOPLE DECIDED TO FOLLOW ME
OVERNIGHT.
THE BIRTHDAY PICTURES ARE GREAT
AND ALL BUT I FIND THAT VERY
HARD TO BELIEVE.
GOT LIKE 500,000 NEW FOLLOWERS
OR SOMETHING WEIRD WAS
HAPPENING.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
JESSICA, LET'S SAY THIS WAS
UNDER A DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATION
AND THE POLITICAL BIAS AND
IDEOLOGY WERE GOING IN A
DIRECTION YOU DIDN'T LIKE, YOU
WOULD BE SCARED.
THIS PERSON IS A LEFT-WINGER WHO
DISMISSED THE LAPTOP BEFORE
THERE WAS EVEN ANY EVIDENCE.
SHE JUST DID IT BECAUSE SHE KNEW
SHE HAD TO DO WIN AN ELECTION.
YOU WOULD BE SCARED TOO.
HE CAN'T HAVE A BUREAUCRAT WITH
AN IDEOLOGY IN CHARGE OF SPEECH.
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE ANYBODY IN
CHARGE OF SPEECH.
>> EVERYBODY IS ENTITLED TO
THEIR IDEOLOGY, WE'RE JUST NOT
SUPPOSED TO KNOW ABOUT A PURITY
WORK IN
THERE.
>> Greg: YOU DO THAT BUT YOU
DON'T DO YOUR BUSINESS.
>> THAT IS DISGUSTING AND I
WALKED RIGHT INTO IT.
SHE WAS LIVE TWEETING THE
PRESIDENTIAL SPACE, YOU COULD
MAKE THE CASE THAT SHE CERTAINLY
HAD MORE LEFT-LEANING OPINIONS
ALTHOUGH SHE DOES HAVE A PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE BACKGROUND AND WAS AT
A NONPARTISAN CENTER DOING HER
WORK.
SHE HAD A LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN
RUSSIA IN BELARUS.
>> Greg: WOODROW WILSON.
>> Jessica: I KNOW, BUT THE
POINT IS TO TARGET
MISINFORMATION ABOUT RUSSIA AND
ALSO THE BORDER, WHICH I THINK
IS INTERESTING AND SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD HAVE KILLED THE
CONSERVATIVES AND ONE EXAMPLE
THEY THROUGHOUT IS ACROSS
FACEBOOK AND WHATSAPP IN HAITI
THEY HAD MISCONSTRUED WHAT BIDEN
SAID ABOUT IMMIGRATION POLICY,
ESSENTIALLY SAYING HE WAS GOING
TO WELCOME EVERYBODY AND 14,000
HAITIANS SHOWED UP AT A BORDER
TOWN AND WERE TRYING GET INTO
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING NOW IS THEY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO TAP INTO
PROBLEMS LIKE THAT IS STOPPABLE
FOR ANOTHER 40,000 PEOPLE SHOW
UP AND SAY WE HEARD THERE IS AN
OPEN BORDER HERE AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO GET IN.
IN TERMS OF WHETHER THIS IS
LEGAL OR WITHIN THE RIGHTS OF
DHS TO DO, I DON'T KNOW, THEY
CERTAINLY FEEL THIS WAY BUT
THEY'VE BEEN ORGANIZING FOR
MONTH.
A WOMAN CAME OUT AND SAID THIS,
IT WASN'T LIKE SOMETHING
HAPPENED OVERNIGHT.
>> Greg: FAIR ENOUGH BUT IF
THEY WERE ORGANIZING IT FOR
MONTHS THE FIRST THING THEY
SHOULD DO IS ADDRESS THE
MISCONSTRUED BORDER ISSUE.
THEY IGNORED ALL THE CONCERNS,
THEY WENT AFTER A GUY, LET US
THE FIRST THING, THAT IS THE
EXAMPLE THEY SHOULD HAVE USED.
YOU KNOW WHAT, THAT WOULD'VE
BEEN REALLY SMART.
WE SCREWED UP AND ACTUALLY
PRODUCED MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION, WE BLAMES THE
WRONG GUY, WE FOUND OUT THAT WAS
INNOCENT.
I WOULD TRUST THEM MORE.
>> WOULD YOU, THOUGH?
>> I AM AN OPEN MIND, A LOVING,
OPEN-MINDED PERSON.
I THINK WE SHOULD START TESTING
THIS ON "THE FIVE."
START SAYING THINGS THAT THEY
WOULD SAY IS DISINFORMATION.
>> Jessica: LIKE YOU ARE A
LOVING GUY?
>> Greg: RIGHT, I WANT TO
FACT-CHECK THAT.
SHE PROBABLY HATES "THE FIVE,"
THAT LADY.
SH